o primeiro turno nós que é o modo de ver
é no sentido em que não é uma opção não
é negócio é uma técnica da produção é
uma maneira de estar na vida
uma dúvida nossa visão que os avantes
para as profissões
deus precisa não é porque as pessoas já
não se mostra de que já não há maneira
de estar na vida não é uma forma de
estar na vida é uma maneira de ganhar
dinheiro pouca coisa qualquer para
consumo
talvez o que faz 30 anos foi poder criar
a qualquer coisa que venha comigo como
já faz favor
eu gostaria de estar sempre que
conseguia fazer sem destino
ele era uma realidade a obra em execução
neste momento muita gente tem é
encontrar se naquilo que eu numa sua
vida deseja sim será sempre é importante
todos nós estejamos nós temos que ser
frios de ser conscientes também que
pensa a quando se continuar assim é
simples lech principal será em coxim e
esquecemos de tudo e curtir e a pegar
numa coisa que é que é preciso ter um
peso loja os dois pés ou este peso o que
faria escreveu vocês
a tesco ou este pezco a primeira coisa
que nos aparecem o valor em lesões
grande
temos que prestar bastante atenção para
encontrar a origem o país caiu duas
vezes na região
eu não sei qual é porque dos pesos
o centro de artes culinárias e evitou
esta unidade investir os dias têm
hospitais e as frutas crescem cada mês
este é o mesmo do peso quando chegou a
supermercados para além do valor eu
tenho a função eo rico idéia de comprar
um texto um peso extra vincent no seu
seio os termos ficado e final vai a
agora está em 10% escondidos
afinal posso comprar um kilt pesquisas
por um euro
a ideia de gastar 10 cêntimos ou 20
cêntimos o que acontece nesta forma de
regulagem é que nós compramos em vez de
um texto compramos dois que os pescoços
eu não sei se amanhã o teste pescoço
então minha atitude vai ajudar em
princípios província européia no
relatório fugindo de 2016 que saiu agora
em abril 26 deste ano disse que um terço
da produção total é desperdício é
desperdício no produtor é desperdício no
transporte e é desperdício nas nossas
casas igualmente os pés que fique
trouxeram de fruta fire with fire
estabelece uma relação com o produtor e
alguém diz não por mim porque nós plínio
por vocês
que espécie que não tem grades canal
mercados não tá aí a forma de chá da
reunião que nunca exige uma perfeição
não tem o peso e não tenha escrito
triste que as duplas nos dizem crescer o
que está ao nosso dispor
o furto foi até neste momento ninguém
sem opções cogitadas 901 em lisboa 200
no porto e recupera cerca de 600
toneladas por semana
imaginemos sua vez em tantas frutas
falhas quanto regiões
compreenderíamos ainda mais com asas de
de alimentos
hum
eu acredito que é somos todos
inteligentes que o ser humano tem uma
inteligência inata e nosso forma de
desligar essa inteligência inata é nós
conhecemos realmente como é comum e usei
comum é ver a terra ver onde chegam as
coisas conhecer as pessoas que fizeram
crescer tal como origem a maioria dizia
muitas vezes não impeçam tomadas em
jornais porque ela não conseguia ter
tomado regionais
ela só conseguia ter tomados em maio em
junho quando começou a era digital
maria lugar com sabão que o tse os
museus virtuais começava a surgir no
japão as praias artificiais
os beats dons e nos anos 90 eu dizia que
nós não queríamos por via de ligação
local
nós sabíamos que estávamos e vier apenas
e fixação do real durante todo ano
quando vou ao supermercado quando vou a
qualquer mercado eu tento a título do
ano
e olhe potes matiz maio tem a mesma
forma
merece brilhantes normalmente bastante
limpo o quarto temático e tem
investimento têm a mesma cor vermelha
mas a principal função do tomate para
mim é quando o indivíduo quando eu como
e quando eu com várias são as vezes que
não tem mais do que uma textura um
conteúdo da água e no fundo eu usarei
infecção do ultimato porque existe na
natureza em de tomate todo ano nesse
momento preocupo mais em tudo que é o
alimento tudo o que minha escolha seja
criança nasce ficaria cresceu perto de
mim pra mim não faz muito sentido
defender é filosofia que tudo o que eu
como é biológico
para mim não faz sentido eu comer uma
sandes
são biológicas mas que vieram ditália eu
prefiro o brasil de novo
além das baianas o possível meu sangue
vai em palmela
não faz muito sentido tamanho pra mim
que o pequeno-almoço enfim uma salada de
manga está em vigor os morangos tenha
sido mais vezes tem este específicos
magníficos não preciso mangas que vieram
estão longe quiseram viajar tudo pescar
ao pé de mim eu acredito que o vasco
tecnológica e científica traz imensos
benefícios como a atual
durante cada vez melhor as doenças e
vivemos sem qualquer dúvida muito melhor
que há 100 anos
segundo o primeiro a gente tem em
portugal é 1920
neste momento outra coisa' em cinco anos
a esperança média de vida vivida em 1924
100 anos era 35 anos
neste momento temos quase nos 80 anos
significa que estamos a construir um
mundo melhor e é nisso que eu acredito
eu acredito que desperdiçamos
segundo ele o pai é um terço do que nós
consumimos do que adquirimos também
podemos melhorar isso não citamos de
encher a nossa casa encher os armas nas
garagens dos alimentos que nós não
sabemos se vamos crise porque eu acho
que a alimentação é uma forma de se
preservar uma forma de nós nos tornarão
sustentáveis mas é uma forma de darmos
precisa nós próprios
eu acredito que neste momento é da
gastronomia que viva em todo mundo e que
tem sentido nos últimos anos quer
obrigar a humanizados olhar presentes
porque não existe nada fora de nós e nós
pegamos nigerinos a não ser o alimento
eu acredito que qualquer um nós já
prendeu pelo menos umas mané é eu
escolher um computador ou telemóvel que
os amigos todos os dias vamos ver aquele
triste quer eu quero um giga do ramo que
era uma placa gráfica porque eu quero
editar vídeos
eu quero um sem número de
características
o google vai junto de views ter que me
sustenta vidas que é triste que se
finalmente é adquirir esse produto
raras são as vezes que demoramos meia
hora de escolher o peso que vamos trazer
para casa
vamos colocar sobre a mesa e vamos
partilhar com os outros
oferecemos os preços em dezembro mas não
são portugueses nem 31 realmente o q3
perto de mim eu quero
sabemos que a alimentação a forma como
os alimentandos nós vivemos todos os
índios não existe outra atividade humana
que envolva e os incêndios quando nós
comemos e não quer só forma e não se
criam um dos mais perfeitos eu escolhi
uns mates e sai que os tomates que não
sei que eu posso comer em maio em
assunção os melhores
long que em dezembro até se fazer um
arroz carolino arroz malandrinho os meus
amigos e que seja tomadas que não vai
comprar os chamados mas procuro usar
tudo que está na estação
não raras vezes quando prepara um jantar
com os amigos ópera os clientes
sou capaz de passar três ou quatro dias
para preparar uma refeição por quatro
pessoas
eu faço realmente aquilo que amo e é
cozinhar hoje em dia têm mais
capacidades pelo mestrados em ciências
gastronômicas que permita observar o que
eu estou a fazer entender melhor a
relação das razões que estão a ocorrer e
e sim trabalhar num produto final melhor
máscara quando é que nina chega à mesa e
os amigos sabem mas achei de estudos não
visto não sei está noites você acha que
estes dias todos é cozinhar para nosso
trabalho e para mim não é um trabalho
que aumentos para mim não é porque eu
tenho que fazer e naturalmente que tem
que fazer porque a alimentação é nossa
sustentabilidade
mas é realmente porque eu quero fazer as
vezes que alguém chegou ao pé de mim e
distribui
este ano inteiro foi comprar um
telemóvel
passaste oito horas de teoria por baixo
de luzes neon comprar este telemóvel que
vai pegar em dez prestações
ninguém nunca investiram em relação a
isso e é realmente um esforço é
realmente vida mas nós colocamos uma
orientação geral que nos parece ser
comum a alimentação já não davam tanta
importância
as nações unidas dizem que ainda agora
uma em cada nove opções está mal nutrida
um objetivo das nações unidas é que em
2020 eles seja algo da forma e fome por
falta de recursos
o fórum é por falta de acesso à fórmula
1 acontece porque é um desperdício isso
nós pensarmos - futebol que é
maravilhoso portugal
nós podíamos praticamente tudo que nós
necessitamos fiquei pasmada quando li o
relatório produzir 70% da carne que
consumindo falta de produção na na fruta
mas na grande maioria tudo o que
produzimos é quase o suficiente e quadro
torna do sup sustentável eo pergunto
isso compramos esse um terço comprarmos
um terço que precisamos comprar um dos
menos se o pavimento espaço armazenar
uma coisa que nós não conseguimos ver
mais nada assim tão bem a energia
elétrica é fabuloso é uma energia é
produzida e se nós não conseguirmos
ganhar pt baterias para gozar
normalmente ela disse pipas o mesmo que
dizer que os alimentos a terra produz o
que fazia a minha avó era a época das
mensagens até ela tinha uma uma adega e
colocava os bravos mofo na adega naquela
frescura e uns 500 mensagens todo ano
mas não era preciso desaproveitar as
unidades da da natureza para que mais
mensagens sejam produzidas e deitadas no
chão
não elas eram cumpridas e guardadas e
cuidadas e o assunto é alimentação e era
da gastronomia neste momento exatamente
se é que estamos todos no
no jantar todos no sítio que nos carros
e que nos dá prazer
se tivermos todos no sítio nos cabe nos
lá prazer eu acho que deveríamos todos
com mais harmonia e deveríamos todos com
menos cheias com mais valorizados
estes dois pés que estão o tomate que
está a terminar
estava nos propôs a experimentarem um
terço da de fruta faz um quase voltar à
infância à origem e por vários assuntos
que é feita esta peça de fruta onde
temos que voltar para trás
eu acredito que apenas é preciso
suspender o movimentos que não é ligado
conosco que é chegar nos engajarmos
porque parece que não vai faltar tudo é
sentirmos ferramenta extremos e criamos
o tesco fernando pessoa dizia situa em
tudo o que faço
acho que é o mais importante estamos
vivos termos estes milagres de vida
dentro 9 e que mais podemos fazer senão
aquilo que está ligado a nós esta
proposta da fruta
eu acho que estava que partilhassem com
quem tem o lado tem uma faca e tem um
guardanapo e provassem desse pescoço
eu acredito que são gestos que nos torna
humanos
após a rotatória já voltei aos norte
quer alugar com 2009
sonhei que eu cheguei ao assunto eu
sempre pegava o carro embora com praia
ser assim
ae
o gol
e que não consegue ver pensado
dois grupos